emprisonné pour fraude.
J’ai été malhonnête, et j'en ai payé le prix.
Avant cela, j'avais été avocat pendant 30 ans.
J'avais eu une enfance heureuse et stable,
une bonne éducation,
un mariage heureux qui, par bonheur, continue.
J'ai deux fils adultes.
Quand ils étaient petits, j'ai fait de mon mieux
pour être auprès d'eux le plus possible.
Et je faisais attention à ce qu'ils faisaient.
Tous les soirs, je lisais une histoire à mes garçons,
et, ironie du sort, notre livre préféré était « Bill, le voleur ».
(Rires)
Mais, une fois en prison, il m'est vite apparu évident
que mon éducation était très différente de celle de la plupart des détenus.
Peu d'entre eux avaient reçu une éducation décente.
Pour beaucoup, l'éducation était synonyme d'humiliation et d'échec.
Pour l'avoir vécu, je peux vous dire que la prison déshumanise.
Les détenus se durcissent, se renferment sur eux-mêmes,
juste pour survivre.
Et cela peut être dévastateur pour les familles.
De fait, garder le contact avec votre famille depuis une prison
peut être vraiment très difficile.
Et si un enfant arrive à voir ses parents en prison,
il doit être fouillé comme les adultes.
Il franchit les mêmes portiques de sécurité.
Il est reniflé par les mêmes chiens.
Tout ça parce que des enfants
ont été utilisés comme passeurs.
Quand ces enfants arrivent enfin au parloir,
ils sont peut-être fatigués d'un long voyage,
timides, muets, peut-être même contrariés.
Et ce n'est pas facile pour les parents, qui ne s'entendent peut-être pas.
Pour de nombreuses raisons,
plus de la moitié des détenus perdent contact avec leur famille.
Comment peut-on aider les détenus à rester en contact avec leur famille ?
Quand j’étais détenu à Channings Woods,
j'ai travaillé pour une association nommée Storybook Dads.
Storybook Dads a débuté en 2003
quand Sharon Berry, une bénévole, a réalisé à quel point les détenus
souhaitaient rester en contact avec leurs enfants.
Et donc, armée de quelques livres pour enfants,
elle aida les détenus à lire et à enregistrer des histoires
pour les envoyer à leurs enfants.
Ce n’était pas une idée nouvelle. Peu d’idées comme celle-ci sont nouvelles.
Ce sont des idées géniales.
Mais ce fut un succès immédiat.
Vous vous demandez peut-être comment fonctionnent ces enregistrements ?
Est-ce difficile pour les détenus ?
Cela peut-il être éprouvant ?
Le processus de choisir, de lire et d'enregistrer l'histoire
peut être très éprouvant pour les détenus.
La prison est difficile à vivre,
et les détenus ne peuvent pas se permettre de se montrer faibles ou vulnérables.
Mais ce processus d'enregistrement
peut mettre mal à l'aise, contrarier, parfois même sembler un peu trop.
Et souvent les détenus pleurent.
Ils pleurent parce qu'ils regrettent de manquer la vie de leurs enfants.
Ils pleurent parce qu'ils ont honte d'avoir laissé tomber leur famille.
Ils pleurent parce qu'ils ne savent pas comment lire à leurs enfants.
Mais parce qu'on leur offre un espace privé lorsqu'ils viennent, en tête à tête,
les détenus n'ont plus besoin de se montrer fort,
et ils peuvent utiliser leur vulnérabilité comme une force
quand ils parlent à leurs enfants.
Je me souviens d'un détenu qui était venu enregistrer.
C’était un homme grand et fort, avec la réputation d’être dur.
Il est venu, aussi implacable que d'habitude.
Mais lorsque la porte du studio d'enregistrement s'est refermée,
cette façade a commencé à s’effriter
Il a pris un papier chiffonné dans sa poche
et il a commencé doucement à lire
ce qu'il avait écrit pour ses deux petits.
Ses mains tremblaient.
Et d'une voix étonnamment douce,
il a commencé à chanter leur berceuse préférée.
Il ne pouvait pas faire grand-chose de derrière les barreaux
pour montrer à ses enfants qu'ils lui manquaient,
mais ça, il pouvait le faire.
Une fois l'enregistrement terminé,
il est envoyé au service de production de Storybook Dads
à la prison de Channings Wood, dans le comté de Devon.
Et c'est là où j'ai travaillé.
J'ai été formé avec d'autres détenus
à éditer et à produire des enregistrements
provenant de prisons de tout le Royaume-Uni.
Au moyen de logiciels audio et vidéo,
on enlève les défauts des enregistrements
et on y ajoute des bruitages et de la musique.
Et l’expérience et les compétences que les éditeurs-détenus en retirent
les aident pour leurs futurs emplois.
Une fois l'enregistrement finalisé,
il est transféré sur un CD ou un DVD et envoyé à la famille
pour que les enfants puissent le voir dès qu'ils en ressentent le besoin.
Et ils écoutent et regardent beaucoup ces enregistrements.
Au coucher, dans la voiture...
Certains les emmènent même à l’école pour montrer à leurs amis.
Ces enregistrements
montrent aux enfants qu'ils sont aimés et manquent à leur parent.
Et ils montrent au détenu
qu'ils peuvent faire quelque chose pour leur enfant, en tant que parent.
Vous vous souvenez de Sophie ?
Eh bien, un jour, juste avant Noël, un colis arriva.
Voici ce qu'il y avait dedans.
Écoutons ensemble.
(Vidéo) Père Noël : C'est parti, Comet ! Cupid ! Donner et Blitzen !
Charlie: Ce sont ses rennes, c'est ça?
Père Noël: Oui, c'est ça.
Plus haut, plus haut, ils volèrent,
à travers terres et mers, ils se dépêchèrent.
À travers les magiques aurores boréales, ils passèrent -
J'adorerais voir une aurore boréale. Pas toi ?
Charlie : Oui, ça doit ressembler un peu au ventre de ce bonhomme de neige.
Père Noël : Probablement, oui.
Cool, ce bonhomme de neige, non ?
Charlie : Super cool, oui. J'adore.
Père Noël : Ils visitèrent tous les enfants du monde
et laissèrent des cadeaux à chacun d'eux.
En un instant, ils étaient de retour à Grenouilly-les-Prés.
Charlie : (Rires)
Père Noël : Tu trouves ça drôle ?
Charlie : Oui. Je veux vivre là-bas.
Père Noël : Où vis-tu ? À Grenouilly-l'Arbre ?
Charlie : Oh non... Je vis dans cet arbre.
Je l'ai décoré pour Noël. Regarde.
Père Noël : C'est beau.
Tu as très bien travaillé.
Charlie : Merci beaucoup.
(Rires de l'audience)
Alan Crickmore : Sophie et sa mère l'ont écouté trois fois,
et elles n'avaient pas ri autant depuis bien longtemps.
Elles peuvent voir qu'il va bien, qu'il les aime.
Et au prochain coup de fil, Sophie aura plein de choses à dire :
« Que mange Charlie le Chimpanzé ? »
« Est-ce que Papa enverra bientôt une autre histoire ? »
Depuis sa création en 2003, Storybook Dads s'est développé.
Désormais, Storybook Dads et Storybook Mums (pour les mamans) opèrent
dans plus de cent prisons du Royaume-Uni.
98 % des prisonniers qui participent
disent que cela a amélioré leur relation avec leur enfant.
Et depuis 2003,
plus de 60 000 DVDs et CDs ont été envoyés
aux enfants de détenus.
Pour la famille de Sophie et pour des milliers d'autres comme elle,
Storybook Dads est une bouée de sauvetage.
Des détenus disent que c'est la première fois
qu'ils ont commencé à construire une relation avec leur enfant.
Certains qui lisaient difficilement
ont été tellement inspirés par ce dont ils étaient capables
qu'ils ont pris des cours pour s’améliorer en lecture.
Revenons à l'histoire du Vilain petit canard.
Mais là, j'aimerais vous faire écouter un enregistrement fait par un détenu.
Parce que ça résume le pouvoir de ce que nous accomplissons.
Le détenu était un gitan irlandais qui ne savait pas lire,
il voulait envoyer une histoire chez lui pour l'anniversaire de sa fille.
Avec l'aide d'un mentor, et d'un montage astucieux,
il s'est produit quelque chose de magique.
Ceci est un extrait de l'enregistrement de base
où le détenu lit l'histoire en répétant phrase par phrase.
(Audio) Mentor : Il ne pouvait se cacher.
Owen : Il ne pouvait se cacher.
Mentor : Alors un jour, il s'enfuit.
Owen : Puis un jour, il s'enfuit.
Mentor : Il courut jusqu'au grand marais.
Owen : Il courut jusqu'au grand marais.
Mentor : Où vivaient les canards sauvages.
Owen : Où vivaient les canards sauvages.
Et ceci est un extrait d'enregistrement
où l'on a retiré la voix du mentor et ajouté des bruitages et de la musique.
(Audio) Owen : Il ne pouvait se cacher.
Donc un jour, il a fui.
Il a couru jusqu'au grand marais où vivaient les canards sauvages.
Il est resté allongé dans les roseaux deux semaines.
(Musique) (Cris d'oies)
Des canards sauvages et des oies vinrent pour le voir.
« Tu es vraiment laid », lui dirent-ils, et ils se moquèrent de lui.
(Caquètements)
Le vilain petit canard s'enfuit du grand marais.
AC : Et voici comment il termine l'histoire.
(Audio) Il n’était pas un vilain petit canard.
Durant l'hiver, il s’était transformé en un beau cygne blanc.
Les autres cygnes le regardèrent constatant à quel point il était beau.
« Viens avec nous », dirent-ils.
Et c'est ce qu'il fit.
(Cris d'oiseaux) (Musique)
Eh bien Tiara, j’espère que tu as aimé cette histoire,
autant que j'ai aimé te la lire.
J'ai hâte d’être à nouveau avec toi et de te prendre dans mes bras.
Avec tout mon amour, ton papa, Owen.
Plein d'amour. Tu me manques énormément.
Au revoir, mon cœur. Au revoir.
(Musique)
(Fin de la musique)
AC : Quand il a écouté l'enregistrement
avant qu'il ne soit envoyé à sa fille,
il a pleuré.
C'est une réaction assez fréquente chez les détenus,
lorsqu'ils réalisent pour la première fois
qu'ils ont fait quelque chose pour leur enfant
qu'ils n'auraient jamais pensé pouvoir faire.
Ils ont établi une connexion de la façon la plus fondamentale
au moyen d'une histoire.
Quant à Sophie,
elle veut Gruffalo la prochaine fois.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)